can you hear me now okay let's see
maybe it's not the same oh yeah it is
hello hello can you hear me yeah you can
hear me now yeah the sound or what don't
worry about that no maybe I just get a
put back a little bit can everybody hear
me little glitch there I have all these
uh technical glitches technological
glitches sometimes they come out of
nowhere you have no idea how you get
into that trouble they kind of trouble
anyways today I was saying before I was
shut off by the mic I'm gonna be doing a
little brief history of not of time but
of motion what is motion and when you
look at it from a historical point of
view you find out that very few people
dealt with a subject and whenever they
did they did so in a religious context
they wanted to know if the soul moved or
if the soul was the prime mover and
obviously they discussed the issue of
whether there was a first mover an
unmoved mover but I'm getting ahead of
myself let me let me just start here at
the beginning and I'm going to start
with the Greeks they're the ones who
left written word in general about the
first notions of physics geometry etc
and they did so in a somewhat organized
fashion in the sense that they debated
these things among themselves and then
they published they wrote something and
what I'm gonna start with is with Plato
and you have to recall that Plato
invokes other people who do the talking
for him
in all his dialogues and of course one
of those is Socrates and I'm sure that
some of these ideas
were already kicked around with Socrates
and his students before Plato Rotem you
know a few years later after mr.
Socrates had the good fortune of
drinking some hemlock and so well let's
start with Plato here and I got
statement from him and this comes out of
the Timaeus and he says let me move
aside here a little bit see if I can
make this a little bigger motion never
exists in what is uniform for to
conceive that anything can be moved
without a mover is hard or indeed
impossible and equally impossible to
conceive that there can be a mover
unless there is something unless there
is there be something which can be moved
in other words we can't have a mover
without something to move and we can't
have something to move without a mover
ok that was the original thought that
was the original train of thought the
philosophy motion cannot exist where
either of these are wanting and for
these to be uniform is impossible
wherefore we must assign rest to
uniformity and motion to the want of
uniformity ok yeah well you get a you
get a drink a lot of tea - I understand
that way you know essentially but what
I'm what I'm looking at here this is one
of the first statements he makes what
I'd like to focus on today is really
definition of the word motion and also
how it relates to physics because like I
just said a minute ago you know the word
motion has been investigated but mainly
for people who were talking about the
motions of a motion of the soul the
movement of the soul and also if there
was a first mover or how did things
start getting in motion to begin with
and you know if if you think of gods and
things of that nature then you have to
try to justify them on the basis that
that guy is the first mover and that's
what you're gonna see in the first few
people who deal with this subject ok so
the next one he he tries to give a
definition here
many he says that there are six
directions of motion there's one during
backwards and forwards there's light
right and left and up and down those are
the six motions that he defines or or
describes at least in tomatoes and yeah
but then he adds another motion because
he's got to justify the motion of the
celestial spheres in which he says are
spheres okay this is interesting because
the Greeks already had an idea that the
world was round and not flat some like
some people still today try to make you
you know believe in he says the movement
suited to this spherical form he's
talking about the earth here was
designed to him being of all the seven
is he talking about the seven motions
here that which is most appropriate to
mind and intelligence and he was made to
move in the same he's talking about a
God here in the sense and he was made to
move in the same manner and on the same
spot within his own limits revolving in
a circle all the other six motions were
taken away from him in other words the
earth here is not gonna be able to move
back and forth up and down or sideways
the earth can only move in circles and
he says that the earth is spherical and
he was made not to partake in their
deviations okay so apparently the Greeks
already had a notion that the earth was
round spherical and and then they tried
to explain the motion the circular
motion they they've realized that it was
moving some kind of circles there was
constant repetition in in the in the sky
not only the Sun and the moon but you
know the constellation they probably
noticed that as well and so they're
trying to justify this and how do they
justify it on the basis of circular
motion it's not gonna be until Kepler
who comes up with the ellipses okay and
so what's the origin of motion well here
Plato tells us he says
then we must say that self-motion
being the origin of all motions and the
first which arises among things at rest
as well as among things in motion is the
oldest or eldest and mightiest principle
of change and that which is changed by
another and yet moves another is second
in other words he's saying that the guy
if you see something in motion that's
secondary that means that guy was
already moved but the first mover the
first thing that ever moved has to have
self motion this is his argument okay
it's gonna be challenged by mr.
Aristotle and he says and here I want
you to focus on the definition also of
motion because Aristotle gives us one
but he disagrees with Plato and I'm
gonna show that later on when I get into
Saint Thomas Aquinas who essentially
summarizes both of them but he says
Aristotle says does it follow that being
if one is motionless we're talking about
God here right the original source of
motion why should it not move the whole
of it within itself as parts of it do
which are unities yeah which are unities
this water that's an example right again
why is qualitative change impossible and
that's where I went on to do to focus on
the fact that he defines Aristotle
defines motion as change okay that's
he's giving a synonym essentially he
says again why is qualitative
qualitative change impossible so that's
how he defines motion he also has
another synonym Aristotle and he brings
that up in his third book of physics
okay and he says the fulfillment of what
exists potentially is so far as it
exists potentially he says motion is
potential made actuality okay
so what was potential the possibility of
movement is made actuality and that's
essentially what motion is but he says
of what is alterable alterable
alteration okay so of Aristotle is
essentially defining motion as
alteration and also as changes you saw
in this previous notes so he's using
synonyms he's not really telling us what
he means by motion he's just using these
cinema he's saying you know in this case
it's changed and the other one he uses
the word alteration okay and nothing
much happened for hundreds of years
until we get mister thomas aquinas in
13th century and he essentially uses
Plato's and Aristotle's definition which
shows again that nothing much happened
throughout those years as far as
discovering or defining the word what
does what motion is or defining what the
word motion means and Aquinas says
everything that has moved is moved by
another now he gets this from Aristotle
okay he essentially is an Aristotelian
as far as motion he's gonna use this
argument to prove the existence of God
what is he after he's after
Aristotle's unmoved mover the first
source of motion okay that's what he has
in mind and so he he takes Aristotle
he's gonna do a little bit of Plato in a
second here also but he says everything
that is moved is moved by another this
mover is itself either moved or not
moved okay if it is not we have reached
our conclusion namely that we must posit
some unmoved mover this we call God okay
that's the amove mover mister the man
upstairs if it is moved it is moved by
another mover we must consequently
either proceed to infinity or we must
arrive at the same unmoved mover okay
now it is not possible to proceed to
infinity hence we must pause it some
prime unmoved move
he just threw away he didn't like me he
wasn't a mathematician he went but again
all this has to is related to the soul
and God and the Bible and Christianity
okay so Aquinas is is again and Plato
did the same thing by the way
Plato used this notion of the
self-motion and he ascribed that to the
soul okay he says it's the soul he says
a body you know you have a body and you
have a soul the soul enters the body
right and that's the ether I talked
about the other day where the ether
comes from the stars and he penetrates
your body and the soul is what you are
really over that spirit that you have
inside you okay and he says that's the
guy that's gonna do the movie the soul
is is the origin of motion okay the body
is just you know a statue until the soul
penetrates it that was his Plato's idea
and and Aristotle disagreed with that
saying well he was a little more
materialistic and he said well it's not
really the soul it's that there was a
first mover the unmoved mover so now we
have two concepts here the soul from
outer space or from the ether or from
whatever that comes into the body and
gets it moving and that's kind of like a
concept but you know again you have to
remember Plato assigned a form to the
soul okay and then you have Aristotle
who says look there's a mover he's the
guy who set the dominoes in motion okay
that's the difference in a way in a way
that's an interesting comparison because
a rock moves but a rock group requires a
mover like both Aristotle and Plato
agree with me there you know it requires
a mover but the living cell
it doesn't require
it starts moving by itself and now
that's scary because we say hold it what
is a cell well it sells a bunch of atoms
a bunch of molecules you know it's just
strands small rocks moving on themselves
kind of like that it's it's we have all
these rocks will call them atoms and
they're lifeless but when they get
together and have a party you know it's
kind of like they imbue life into this
thing we call cell which is the unit of
life and suddenly the the cell begins to
move and that is quite scary you know
you know if you're yeah I don't know I
guess if you're God or your intelligence
out there in the universe and you see
that all these rocks are just performing
regular motions spinning around each
other and spinning under axes and all
that stuff and everything is fine
because everything is predictable and
suddenly you come across unpredictable
motion which is a cell that moves in the
opposite direction and you say oh oh oh
what is that what happened there that
must be scary even for God you know but
anyways this is what st. Thomas says
okay and that we have to have an unmoved
mover and he gets that from Aristotle
but he takes care in giving credit also
to mr. Plato
he doesn't get rid of Plato completely
in fact he's he's trying to blend Plato
with Aristotle he's saying that they're
talking about two different the same
thing from two different angles that's
essentially what these two guys are
doing and he says the following about it
he says and this again is in the 13th
century you know I have to split it in
two here it is to be noted however that
Plato who held that every mover is moved
in Phaedra's right understood the name
motion or the term motion I guess that's
what he meant in a wider sense then then
did Aristotle for Aristotle understood
motion strictly according as it is the
act of what exists in potency in other
words uh Aristotle said that its potency
made actuality okay that's what motion
is whatever those two words mean Memphis
yeah but whatever was potential now his
main actuality and that's called motion
and so exists in potency in as much as
it is such so understood motion belongs
only to divisible bodies as it is proved
in the physics number six chapter four
according to Plato however that which
moves itself is not a body even though
he talked about the form okay
he's talking about the soul here Plato
understood by motion any given operation
so that to understand and to judge are a
kind of motion
Aristotle likewise touches upon this
manner of speaking in the anima number
book 3 chapter 7 Plato according and he
said that the first mover moves himself
okay what my son just said the cell it
kind of moves by itself it moves moves
himself because he knows himself in
Wills or loves himself so the reason the
the original mover of himself moved was
because he loves himself that goes for
all you egotistic people out there okay
so if you love yourself your move you're
in motion in a way this is not opposed
to the reasons of Aristotle look at this
you saying that even though they come
from different angles that they're not
disagreeing really on on the primary
mover which he's gonna end up with God
right there is no difference between the
reaching a between reaching a first
being that moves himself as understood
by Plato and reaching a first being that
is absolutely unmoved as understood by
Aristotle so we have a being that is
unmoved that's God and a being that can
move himself and that's also God and so
they're just talking about to this
different aspects or properties of God
the ability that to stand still
completely still with respect to
everything else that exists which is
nothing at that point so God can stay
absolutely still not move a single part
of his body and at the same time God has
that ability that magical ability to
start motion within
as a the with him himself or as a
complete entity and that entity is now
gonna set the dominoes in motion he can
move anything else that he wants okay so
those are the notions but read remember
all this is related really more except
for Aristotle I'll give him a little
credit because he's trying to explain
somewhat a little bit about physics even
though he mentions the gods a lot but
Plato and and everyone all the way to
acquaint us they dealt with this issue
only on the basis of what the soul is
and who the first prime mover is which
is God so it was all related to religion
not really their physics it's not like
they went to a lab and they say well
what is motion you know how do we
explain it now they were they were
trying to justify the Bible and they
said well what is motion or how do we
justify the existence of God and one of
the five arguments that Tom st. Thomas
has is that is the unmoved mover that
was his argument and he essentially
takes Aristotle and develops humans in
about 35 arguments
yes prime mover thing is is something
that even physicists hit upon with big
bang or it's like everything's in motion
well if we track back where everything
came from well even before teach even
when trying to say it has this feeling
that the universe is this billiard table
tracks it back to either these things
were always in motion or someone hit the
first ball of the steak and everybody
kind of throws the first one away
because everything always being in
motion just sounds ridiculous or
something because there's no everything
but there's another issue there and
remember Stephen Hawking he in his book
a brief history of time he does go in
there and talk about energy splitting
from energy positive from negative
that's how he creates the universe in
other words yeah there's nothing but
nothing is the blend of positive and
negative
energy and where that energy came from
is never explained and it's just given
as a as a hypothesis you have to grant
it you have to concede it's an
assumption and so there is energy
whatever energy is because energy is a
concept but it turns out that this
concept turn separates physically
because now we're going to talk about
physics separates physically into
positive energy and negative energy
which he names mass positive energy mass
negative energy gravity okay so now we
have gravitation and mass now we're
talking about at least in the case of
mass people at least in their minds they
think well you're talking about now
something a physical object you're
talking about something existing right
massive you know a table has mass you
know tables a physical object so when
you get into the word mass it's like you
suddenly energy morphed into a physical
object and and again since we're talking
about motion the point you that I'm
trying to make here is that the way
hawking explains that you have motion of
energy self motion of energy somehow the
the heavens split apart and you have
positive energy here negative energy
over there so now you start getting
matter from absolutely nothing which is
energy so if that makes any sense to you
but that's the reasoning if you have
energy and energy is the blend of
gravity and mass and and you can use the
euphemisms or metaphors called positive
and negative energy well you know when
you split them apart now you have real
things in the universe so again
something from nothing okay in in a
sense so if you split space you have in
fact today in fact in today we have
another
angle to that same notion to that same
concept and that's that in the vacuum
you know the vacuum of se in the when
they go to the accelerators they split
space they pull particles out of space
right and so you can say that when
they're in space they're like in this
mass of particles that don't move
you would think because you know at
least Newton held that you know space
does not move you figure that one out
but now we're pulling a particle from
space a virtual particle comes into
detection into visibility into whatever
you want to call it you know just
somehow gets taken out of that mass of
space that's surrounding us the particle
comes in does its job because it lasts
for a very split second and goes back to
where it was and so there is motion the
particle is moving I mean you would have
to think that they're talking about some
kind of motion the particles coming out
of the space that that alone is motion
and then he goes back into the space
that's motion too so again we have all
these subtle motions out there that
nobody really justifies or explains ok
well I'm young I'm gonna try to get the
see okay the image is blurry coming out
blurry let me see it okay okay so what
do we have now well we have then comes
Newton he comes in the seven what in the
17th century and asks 400 years after
Aquinas okay and he's the first guy who
tackles the word motion again I was not
true I mean we had other people like
Descartes and so on I'm not gonna look
at all the milestones because there were
no milestones though the next milestone
is really Newton and what does Newton
say he says I do not define it and he
says this in his
Oh Liam he writes us in iske Liam which
was written in Latin and that's a
Scullion to Principia his main work
dammn 1689 versions edition says i do
not define time space place and motion
as being well known to all so since we
all know what motion is why do you find
it why take the trouble you know we
don't have to be fine yeah in a way
because you know keep in mind that
newton's been credited with the three
laws of motion first law second law and
third law right and so they're called
laws of motion and you would think that
the guy who invents or discovers the
laws of motion he would at least define
the word motion what he's talking about
and here newton starts i think it's the
third sentence down says i do not define
motion as being well known to all so if
we know what it is why should he take
the trouble to define it and and but he
does give a little definition there
right after that and like two paragraphs
or three down and he says absolute
motion is the translation of a body blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah okay so he
uses the word translation again a
synonym because if you look up the word
translation well what does it mean its
motion
I can't imagine translation without
motion and again whether you use the
word change or alteration as Aristotle
used or translation as Newton uses you
still don't know what motion is because
all these people are using synonyms okay
and but what I like about Newton he also
defines rest we have motion but we also
have rest no motion real absolute rest
is the continuance of the body in the
same part of that immovable space in
which the ship itself he gave an example
of a ship right its cavity and all that
it contains is moved so you say the ship
is moving but you're not moving with
respect to the ship if you stand in the
same place so what he's essentially a
pretty here I think is that this is the
notion of this of the frame of reference
which is going to be used later on by
Einstein and all these other folks too
to justify you know position what is
your position well it's what is the
frame of reference so so again Einstein
uses this as a relative motion or
relative location position as they call
in math and I think Newton's the first
one to come up with this he's saying you
know if you stand on the ship and you
hold the same distance from the walls
and the ceiling you always stand still
there even if the ship moves you know
you're moat you don't have any motion
with respect to the walls of the ship
and that's what he talked about when he
says absolute rest he's introducing
essentially the concept of frame of
reference okay and we don't see any you
know I mean you have Maxwell also he he
came up with laws but he never defined
motion as per se and neither did any of
the other folks like in the 19th century
it never happened but we have mr.
Einstein he comes in 1905 and he writes
an interesting one of his four unloosed
mirabilis papers and the paper i'll read
it's called on the electrodynamics of
moving bodies know if he's gonna talk
about moving bodies he would think that
was a minimum he would you find what
movie means what this movie me I mean
you know when you call the movers to
move your your stuff from your house we
pretty much know what moving means right
but here we're talking about a
scientific paper right and this is the
only notion that he puts in an entire
paper the closest he gets to a
definition or a description of motion he
says if we wish to describe described
right the motion of a material point
okay we got a point but it's material
okay we give the values of its
coordinates as functions of the time so
he's talking about frame of reference
again they're talking about Cartesian
coordinates and he started about time he
introduces time to try to justify motion
okay - or describe or define motion now
we must hear carefully in a bear
carefully in mind that a mathematical
description of this kind has no physical
meaning unless we are quite clear as to
what we understand by time and of course
the entire paper is not about motion the
entire papers about time okay he wants
to show that time is relative is that
because he is basing his definition you
can't define motion until he defined
time I'm not sure that's that's the case
I I think that he simply like Newton
says well we all know what motion is so
I'm not gonna in a scientific paper
begin by defining motion so it's like
you know we all know what motion is so
let's worry about time because we don't
know what that is and what what he
showed in this paper which is I guess
the early special relativistic paper
which did not get developed until three
years later 1908 thereabouts you know in
this paper he's kind of giving a hint of
what he's up to he's gonna show you a
relativistic time he's gonna start
saying it all depends on the observer
and that's why he introduces the notion
of frame of reference and why he
introduces the notion of time - to
justify motion so when he talks about
you know the title is very misleading as
addendum under electrodynamics of moving
bodies but he's not gonna talk about
moving bodies he's going to talk about
time that's what he's interested in okay
so yes in a sense he's using time to
define motion which it should be the
other way around because I'm sure we
were gonna talk about motion before we
introduced an observer and time you
won't get until you get an observer you
need memory to talk about time you don't
need memory to talk about motion and
that my definition at the end of the
talk will show that okay but we get to
well in between there's just a comment I
want to make and that's that mister
Heisenberg Werner Heisenberg in 1927 he
comes up with the famous uncertainty
principle
full of indeterminacy and that's a funny
one because essentially and the way I'm
gonna interpret it he says that you know
the more you know about the position of
a particle the less you know about its
momentum and vice-versa the more you
know about its momentum the less you
know about its position and what I'm
saying is that what he just said is that
when the ball moves it doesn't stand
still and when it stands still it
doesn't move no kidding so talking about
motion here you're talking about again
another of scientific paper this one
garnered Werner his Nobel Prize and what
did he say he said essentially that you
know that when you know more about when
when a ball starts rolling to a point
where it stands still at that point we
don't know anything about its motion and
when it starts moving again we know very
little about its position and again and
it's just this idiotic principle that
underlies quantum mechanics but anyways
what do we get to today what do we have
do we have any good definition that we
can use well this is the definition I
found at the Wikipedia and the Wikipedia
says in physics motion is a change in
position change in position of an object
over time so they also introduced time
and when you look up the word position
it says a Euclidean vector that
represents the position of a point P so
they use the word position to the final
position in space in relation to an
arbitrary reference origin oh ok so he's
saying that position is a vector and we
don't know what position means because
you use the word position to define
position but the point here is that if
you put that word position or that
phrase into the first definition you say
motion is a change in position and what
is position position is the position of
a point that's what a position is okay
and they add motion of a body is
observed by attaching a frame of
reference to an observer and mesh
the change in position again change in
position of the body relative to that
frame okay so in other words this is all
mathematical stuff that they want to
introduce as science and they say look
you want to know what motion is well you
first we need to get a frame of
reference okay a Cartesian coordinate
system of some kind and once we get that
we get a position and then we have a
change in position with respect to that
coordinate system that's it that's the
the notion or definition or description
of the word motion today officially and
then if you look at it in the
dictionary.com also has a definition
which is pretty much in the same line of
reasoning they say the action or process
of moving motion is the action or
process of moving or of changing place
or position a change is motion and
another definition in that same from
another dictionary within dictionary.com
says the process of continual change in
the physical position of an object so
that's it we have what is motion it's
changed and if you look up change its
motion you can't do change without any
kind of motion so we don't know what the
definition is unless we use a synonym
and from Einstein all the way to the
Greeks we had the same problem no one
really defined a word motion they never
knew that in a scientific way in a way
we can use it consistently in a rational
way and most of that history if you go
through there is related to God into the
soul they wanted to show that at all
cost that there is a prime mover or
unmoved mover and they also worried
about whether the soul moves in the soul
obviously penetrated your body and get
you to move so you didn't move you were
just a little statue that until the soul
penetrated your body you know you had no
motion and so that's those are the
notions we had throughout history now
why am i concerned about this I'm
concerned because you know one of the
things that you'll note is that
this is a very keyword in science you
need to know what motion is in science
that you need to know what an object is
in science in physics you can't do
physics without an object and I'm sure
you can't do physics without the word
motion you're gonna use the word motion
and in some way or another Newton's
equation acceleration that you also have
momentum you know what are these words
well these words represent motion you
have velocity what is what is speed what
is the speed of light you're talking
about motion so you can't do physics
without either the word object or the
word motion and either of these two
words have ever been defined so I'm
gonna take a crack at it in fact I did
and a lot of you already are familiar
with it but I'll put it up here so that
we know where we stand on this issue I
do define these words think you can't up
cannot avoid them object that which has
shape distance is the separation between
objects location is the distances from
all objects to the target object to the
you want in question and motion two or
more locations of an object now we don't
we're not using synonyms because
location or object are not synonyms of
motion and we're saying what motion is
what we mean by the word motion if you
have an object and it occupies at least
two locations you know then you have
motion and what is a location well if
you take the set of distances from that
object to all the rest in the universe
that's its location with respect to
absolute location with respect to the
rest of the matter in the universe and
what is this since it's a separation
between objects what is an object that
which has shape period so we don't get
into this fancy stuff of who's the
primary mover or was there an unmoved
mover is the soul an object no I don't
define motion because we already know
what it is you know or or start giving
like Einstein his presentation without
you finding what motion is when he's
talking about the moving bodies no here
is straightforward and these are concise
they're crisp they're rigorous and
rigorous only because we
using consistency that's what I mean by
rigorous and again motion two or more
locations of an object now you can
understand what I'm saying if I have a
show you a film and something is moving
in there for sure in each frame of the
film I'm gonna have a different location
for that object and you can split it up
as many times as you want because motion
is not discrete in that sense motion is
only discrete in the sense that it's
built up of locations but locations of
an object in the universe is like Plato
and Aristotle also thought about them
they said what's continuous it's say
it's not chopped up and motion is not
chopped up but for the definition you
need to chop it up because it's based on
the notion of location location is a
static concept location means that you
know I'm not gonna move anything I'm
just gonna define location that's a set
of distances from all objects in the
universe that means at that moment in
time you took a snapshot of the universe
God took took his camera took a picture
of the universe and so that's the
location of this atom in the universe
okay now if that atom in the next frame
has found somewhere else now we have
motion you need at least two frames of
the universal film to conceptualize
motion is motion discreet in a sense yes
in in a sense no it's not in the sense
that it's built of location and each
location is a discrete entity because
it's defined as a static concept but
motion is obviously continuing continues
which is the wrong word again I use the
word incessant motion is incessant this
is a I put that in the book by the way
to explain what motion is and I invoke
mr. God you know the man upstairs and he
comes in and gods watching his creation
and aside from God you know
we're gonna put him aside he spirits so
he doesn't move or or whatever you want
to think of it he's not an object so so
God is a spirit but he's got this
universe in front of him all the atoms
here and they're just it's a frozen
universe that's what I call it the
frozen universe what does it take to
move the entire universe all you need is
to move one atom as soon as you move it
to the left everything else moved to the
right with respect to that atom so all
you need to get the universe to move is
to move one atom of course that never
happened the universe again is eternal
in both directions of time if we're
going to talk about time in the sense
that there was no beginning to the
universe the universe has always been
there and we have trouble understanding
that because it what do you mean how can
it always have been there well there's
no way you're gonna answer that question
for for sure by introducing God or
energy like God for example Christianity
introduces God the mathematical
physicists introduce energy or Big Bang
and then they have trouble explaining
what what came before you know and
people say well how did the first
thought come in they're out at that
singularity explode where did the
singularity come from or where did the
energy come from if you're gonna use the
energy explanation and again there's no
explanation for that so no matter how
you look at it you're not gonna be able
to answer it all you gotta make the
assumption of is that matter has always
been there and the reason for that is
that matter cannot convert into space
and space cannot convert into matter you
cannot have space suddenly you know you
have emptiness vacuum space void
whatever you want to call it zero zip
and suddenly look you have a 3d I don't
know 3d ball no way you cannot explain
what what triggered it another motion so
so so we got a problem there and it's
likewise you can't have a ball turn into
absolute empty space into nothing it
cannot disintegrate to the point where
it converts into nothing it can maybe
transform itself into a square or a cube
or some other object a tree but it can
turn into space into absolutely nothing
he cannot lose length with a night
so if matter cannot turn into space into
vacuum and vacuum cannot turn into
matter we have to assume that the
universe or matter has always been there
it's been it's eternal if the universe
is always in motion does that mean the
universe will always be in motion by
definition the universe will always be
in motion yes in other words in both
directions of time if we're going to
talk about time we're in those terms if
we say well what is time well time is
what we have here on earth we humans
invented we don't yeah and again I say
that nothing's gonna stop motion it's
impossible to stop motion because it's
impossible to stop it's like I think
it's the same question as saying that
can a ball turn into space it can't a
ball can't turn into space and in the
same way if everything is in motion
what would stop what would freeze the
universe and that's unimaginable
something external would have to freeze
it or put it to a stop to blind it to
stop it just slowly winds down slowly
winds down why would it wind down went
down when you roll a ball eventually it
stops moving yeah but a ball encounters
friction air gravity here we're talking
about you know this mass of all these
objects in a you know all these atoms
and whatever and they're kind of
spinning around each other and moving
around none of them can you know they
can change their position their location
with respect to each other one planet
with respect to another one atom with
respect to another gas molecule with
respect to a gas molecule but what they
can't do is scratch their elbows against
space so so it's not like the whole mass
which is what we're talking about
whether the universe the entire man
matter of the universe can grind to a
stop why because in order for it to
grind us
it would have to have friction against
space and it'd have friction against
itself that's what I'm saying
no because what would you have I mean
this has been debated like you know if
all this mass and again we're talking
about the obvious we're eventually
pulled by gravity right by gravity comes
to a ball let's assume that's the case
right so we have all the matter in the
universe gradually over the trillions of
years finally comes and forms a ball
right and the question is is that ball
static and in other or is it spinning is
it a perfect ball is it an irregular
ball and you get a look at these things
because maybe the ball is spinning and
you still have motion no no no you will
have because the atom that's on this
side of this ball is different in the
atom on this side of this ball so now
this guy is moving with respect to that
guy not with respect to the year there's
no absolute space out there we're
talking about motion of this guy with
respect to this guy it's always the same
well we don't know if it's the same what
was you'd have to compare it to a third
thing that's outside of the ball well
again the question is whether you're
going to get in your regular ball and
there's two things what if it's in the
regular ball and whether things are
still in motion I mean are we talking
about a solid ball that's completely
compressed where all the in these case
of the threads right we're talking about
atoms built out of threads and ropes and
so on are we saying we we got rid of all
the ropes
we're squashing these things again we
you know if you look at how atoms are
made with elements are made with in the
Sun you know they're being squashed
together can you imagine all the matter
in the universe all the atoms being
squashed I mean I don't know what it
would be inside there though the
pressure of that whole thing would
continue squeezing and squeezing easy
somewhere it's got to go so I don't
think you can imagine this thing in a
sense that I don't think you could
imagine it in the sense that it's static
that you just have a ball
there and even if it rolls it's a
perfect ball and then even if it rotates
everything maintains the same distance
with respect to each other I don't think
you can produce that ball with all the
matter in the universe if the universe
came together I think you would have
some other physical effects my reasoning
for why the universe will always be in
motion yeah you don't need to try to
imagine the static universe just the
mere fact that it's always been in
motion so there wasn't a time it started
it always was in motion then obviously
nothing can stop it yeah yeah and and
this is this is the issue under the Rope
model I think that no matter when you
are born whether you are born in this
day and age or if we move a trillion
years later I think you'll find the same
thing you'll find galaxies rotating
around galaxies and humans being born in
some planet and somewhere in the
universe I think that's what you'll find
I don't think that changes ever so even
when we're gone don't worry about it you
know somebody else will come along and
they'll have the same discussion we had
today they say you know what is motion
how did motion start and all that stuff
and some will go with God and some will
go the rationalist will go and say well
let's see what is motion that's to two
locations of an object with two
locations many positions yeah yeah yeah
but you get a look at what unit you're
concerned yeah you're gonna talk about
the atom or you're gonna talk about the
ball that you gotta identify the system
if we're gonna talk about the motion of
this ball right then you know we're
talking about two locations of the ball
now we're gonna talk about an atom well
let's forget about that it comes the
object ball let's look at the object
called atom does the ad does that atom
move with respect to the rest does its
distance change so you get identify the
that's important but no I personally you
know I cannot imagine how the whole
universe comes to a stop
I can't imagine also how the entire
universe comes and forms a ball well I
don't know because you gotta consider
imagine a really big ball yeah but see
imagine in that sense yeah but I mean it
unimaginable in the sense that if you
factor gravity and other things and
other physical notions that we already
have out there no it does have a lot no
no then you then you can't get it in -
yeah but see it's more than that it's
the you know you you get these this
matter coming together right
gravitationally but once the matter gets
crushed
what happens after certain density or
the certain mass that you've got
together if if we know that some of
these stars which are monsters and many
times the size of artists on right and
there are big stars and supposedly they
crunch matter and maybe they produce
uranium course for all we know because
they're just so massive that you know
they they form all these radioactive
materials the high level of materials
the heavy ones from the periodic table
you know that's a big star now what
happens if you take all the matter in
the universe and begin to crunch it into
a ball well I don't know what's
happening is I wouldn't like to be in
the center
I'd be squeezed the hell out of
existence you know no in fact in my book
I say that the only conceivable
perpetual machine is the universe it's
the only conceivable machine in other
words our universe is is a closed system
in the sense that matter cannot leave
space because space has no borders to
cross space is not a thing so you cannot
escape space even God can't escape that
which has no borders so you have all
this matter okay
floating in space right and it's all
moving with respect to each other and so
the question is
whether we can put it to a stop and I'm
saying we can't so we have perpetual
motion we do have a closed system
because none of that matter can leave
the space so we have the two condition
we have a closed system right
everything's contained within space
we're going to talk about within there's
no within but you know all this matters
floating out there in space as we say
and can it come to a stop no and if it
can't then it's in perpetual motion we
have to conclude that not only can
matter not convert into space but you
know it's trapped it's it's imprisoned
forever but it's also in motion forever
it's uh it's incessant
it moves incessantly well one I don't
even know about laws and I don't even
know if they were Newtons because I've
seen different versions that preceded
him so Newton kind of borrowed from
others but the first law says you know
that an object continues in a
straight-line motion unless it's
deviated and this something stops it the
second one says force equal mass times
acceleration which is the most famous
law and the third one is the clash your
resistance that let's see if I can
phrase it properly that well one that
you move against something today I
failed the course but it's uh yeah one
pushing against another what was it when
a straight-line motion the other ones
force equals mass times acceleration the
third one is something about resistance
force is a push but but the point is
that you know the these three laws of
motion yeah the only one that for one he
should get credit is the force equals
mass times acceleration because that was
the first in straight-line motion
several people said that in the past so
it's not a Newtonian law if we're gonna
call it a law it was legislated way
before Newton as far as I know the cart
also already talked about straight-line
motion and the third one I think also
the push and pull resistance I'm not
sure but I'm almost sure that people
figured that out way before Newton the
only one we should give him credit is
for the second one but should be given
credit for any of them if he never
defined the word motion I mean how can
you give this guy a Nobel Prize for
saying I got the three laws of motion
when he hasn't defined the word motion
he says well you know what I'm talking
about
is in motion
magnetism is a concept what is in motion
are the threads yeah we have a problem
with some of these concepts when applied
to the Rope model and that's speaking
not because it's because we have a
problem with using these words in the
context of the thread or hypothesis and
that is that does the Rope exists well
if we talk about the word exists in the
concept of in in the context of an
object that has location well the Rope
qualifies as an object it has shape
right but does it have location and we
cover this in a couple lectures ago
where we said you know can you establish
a distance between one rope and another
well conceptually I guess you can but
we've never done that in in the
measuring world in the measuring world
we measure from atom to atom excuse me
we never measured from rope to rope
because we never knew there were ropes
there it's like and let me put it in a
different context so that you see what
I'm talking about
if there's nothing between two atoms if
we're just going to talk about distance
between two atoms
right we have distance here and we have
another pair of atoms here we have
distance here can you take the distance
between the distances that's what we're
asking in terms of the rope in terms of
the rope it makes more sense because now
we have an object we have two ropes
right parallel one to the other and
conceptually we can say is there a
distance between the two ropes and yes
you could you could define the word
distance now in that sense but then you
have the problem is well what point on
the rope are you gonna tell you which
which which little link are you gonna
take yeah I mean they could be in
different positions they're also moving
you know items we can deal with because
we can't say we see them but we see the
objects they comprise ropes there's no
way we're ever gonna see a rope right no
all I'm saying is the word distance has
traditionally been brought down from
mathematics and so we always have this
concept of distance yeah let me get let
me get the measuring tape we get that
and now the question is we get rid of
the table we're not gonna do math we're
just gonna say is there a separation
between ropes and obviously there is but
then you get the other issue and that's
if you have a rope and you're gonna talk
about the separation the distance to all
other ropes and matter in the universe
it gets very very complicated because
what part of the Rope are you gonna take
in the other side of the universe
are you gonna take the middle of the
rope to the ending of the rope it gets
complicated not not like an atom that
which is like a point particle or or a
rounded thing that's there you know now
you're talking about a rule that extends
yeah and then what section of the rope
are you gonna take and no but but this
is what I'm saying
what I'm saying is that yeah there is a
distance and separation between any
portion of any rope to any portion of
any other road there is a separation and
but gets complex and then you got the
question of location what is the
location of that rope and the question
is again are you going to take a little
segment a little link or some 1/4 of a
link you know how much of the link are
you
it's not again like an atom which yeah
atom is always considered we've always
considered as a discrete entity now we
have an elongated entity now to talk
about location is very very difficult
back to the question can it be said that
magnetism is motion or is in motion well
again if if we're gonna strictly by
definitions it's gonna be very tough
because we have trouble defining what
location is what distance or location is
whether the robic ya the rope or the
thread exists assuming we could get
through those hurdles and I need a
smarter people who can tackle the
problem of definitions there you know
maybe there is a way of doing it or
maybe creating some new words
specifically for the rope but once we
get past that hurdle then we can talk
about the motion of the thread because I
am saying that you know the thread is
twirling its ya magnetism so we're
spinning the thread around okay we're
spinning the thread around and it's the
wall of threads that come out of all
these atoms that are a line that is
swinging around and ask what the
magnetic field is and yes if you if one
of the things you'll notice if you go to
the YouTube or even you know if just
look it up you'll find that all magnetic
fields are always Illustrated statically
what moves you know they say is you know
when you well not even the iron value PD
iron filings also fall and they stay in
place right but what they're saying is
moving are the lines of force the lines
of force are the ones that move not the
field the field is static is just like
you know a magnet just has a static
field nothing's moving
but what moves within the magnetic field
are the lines of force and then they say
oh by the way the map the lines of force
are in existent they don't exist we just
use them to to explain you know magnetic
force so they use the lines of force to
explain magnetic force they comprise the
field but the field is static so what
we're saying
now look we have threads now retired on
physical object not about lines which is
a concept not about field which is a
concept we're talking about we're
talking about threads and those threads
are what we traditionally called lines
of force the threads are swinging around
they are moving but then the question
comes up in that forms a magnetic field
but then the question comes up like my
son's here asks very intelligently it
says well does it make sense to say that
the threads move and before you can talk
about the emotional threads you've got
to go back to location before you talk
about a location you gotta go back to
distance and now it gets tricky because
again you know what I said if you have
these ropes where are you gonna measure
not measure but where are you gonna how
are you gonna talk about distance to
other ropes maybe to Adams yes but can
you talk about distance between rows the
separation between all ropes in the
universe well again what chunk of rope
are you gonna talk about and all you can
do in that case is maybe this is the
solution and I'm improvising here now
I'm saying maybe you take the full rope
it doesn't matter because as long as
there is a separation you're not
concerned about well is it this link or
is it that other main the full rope
between two atoms and from Emily right
and we're talking about all the ropes in
the universe if there's gazillions of
ropes then now now we have we have
distance separation from rope to rope
there is a separation of physical
separation we can call it physical here
in other words there is a separation at
distance now can we measure it no well
can we stretch our measuring tape across
well what link are you gonna use so
we're not gonna get into that part but
physically there is a separation like
there is a separation from one atom to
all the other atoms in the universe
yeah there's it's a conceptual issue and
you can say well the location of this
stretch of rope between these two atoms
is that is the separation or the
distance to all the ropes and matter in
the universe and that's simply the space
that separates that rope from all the
other of matter in the universe that's
all you can do and then yeah you can say
that's that's the location of that rope
and now
you have location if the atoms move and
the robe also moves with them or or in
in some way moves because though these
ropes do move you know from one second
to another they're not static in that
sense and so then you can talk about
motion of the rope and also motion of
the thread so knee in that guy and also
about the existence you can talk about
the existence of the Rope motion we got
Thomas here has a question wouldn't
distance always be the shortest
separation between well it doesn't have
to be the shortest shortest is a
mathematical word you know in the sense
that you're gonna measure and say well
this one's 10 centimeters the other word
is 20 so the shortest one is 10
centimeters I don't think you need to
introduce the word shortest or longest I
think all we need to do is say from a
conceptual point of view there is space
between this rope and all the ropes and
atoms in the universe there's there's
separation and that's the location of
that rope imagine your god right and you
say well what's the location of this
rope between these two atoms right
between these two hydrogen atoms right
over here in this in the middle of the
universe well what would he do well he
doesn't get his measuring tape he just
looks and says conceptually that stretch
of rope that one meter piece of rope
right has distance with respect to all
the rest of the ropes and atoms in the
universe all the existing matter so
there is a separation and we can call
that distance to each any any part of
that that you choose and we call the
whole shebang location I think
conceptually when we think of distance
yeah but listen listen this is a good
question because when we think of
distance we think of linear space okay
linear space yeah it's like no you got
to think of it if you if there's
something like a lie
one dimensional line as they say just
that it has width only or height if we
take that little line so as thin as you
can make it and you take it from the
center one atom or the surface from one
atom to the surface of another atom what
we call that distance right we'll call
that the distance that is the rod that
we're going to use to talk about
distance but but again the question is
you know is that what we're trying to do
here and I'm saying that we should not
think of this as just a little line you
can think of it as a plane if you take
two ropes you can put a plane between
them that's one and if there's another
one on top and the other one on the
bottom the other on the side well now
we're talking about 3d and now we won't
use the play we'll use the cube in other
words what I'm saying is that distance
in that context in the context of the
rope and in the context of the thread
has to be viewed in terms of you know
just the space and you can't talk about
linear or think in terms of linear space
but we'll call this a 3d space solid
space we're talking about you know a 3d
extension in every direction and that's
the location of that rope if you're
gonna just talk about that rope well
that's the location of that rope
bischoff it's the rest of the matter in
the universe no problem we need to go a
few more minutes we'll do it because the
subject is very interesting does motion
no no no in fact I distinguished memory
and I distinguished motion from time and
the difference is memory time requires
memory motion does not you say well how
can that be I mean the moon moved right
but the only reason you know this or
that you're aware of this or that you
observe this is because you remember the
moon's previous location that's I have
to write everything only has one
location right about two or more okay
now God swings his magic wand and kills
all human beings in the universe
there are no more intelligent beings
nothing that is alive we don't have time
anymore because we don't have memory
there's no memory now now it's just
rocks swirling in space do we have
motion yes we do have motion because
motion is two or more locations and as
long as an object occupies two or more
locations in the absence of an observer
it's moving so it moves by definition
time on the other hand requires memory
but an object can only have one location
yes only has one location also according
to your definition nothing's in motion
because you don't need the observer well
did the moon occupy two or more
locations on its own yeah the present
the present but if you talk about two or
more locations obviously you're talking
about a previous no you're talking about
a previous location that the object had
irrespective of the observer I mean the
mayor and I mean good time no no you're
not about to position no you're not no
because remember what is location it's
just a set of distances so if so if the
moon occupies two different sets of
differences right on its own world then
there's no memory there's no if the moon
occupy two or more locations that's what
we mean by the word motion we're saying
that when the moon right takes two or
more locations will call that motion
it's a definition in the process now
that's now that's a time no no when you
when you talk about present you're
talking about time I'm not saying time
I'm saying two or more locations
that's time worse time in the definition
two more locations in voc's time because
everything only has one location yeah
well if if the moon if the moon occupies
two or more location or we agreed that
it's got motion
[Laughter]
or memory ok we'll fight this out we've
got the boxing gloves over there and
we'll take care of this tonight now
tomorrow we don't know if any of those
two will be alive to to be online we'll
see you tomorrow okay we'll figure this
out
bye bye